بوتيره متسارعه يتطور ملف حمله الاعتقالات
السياسيه في تونس فيما تسميها السلطه قضيه
التامر على امن الدوله الاحاله على القضاء
واوامر الايداع بالسجن ضد الموقوفين
اجراءات تمت دون مبرر قانوني ولا واقعي
بحسب هيئه الدفاع التي قاطعت الترافع
احتجاجا على ذلك تبين لدى ان الجنب
السياسي هو الجانب المحفز وهو الدافع
لاثاره هذا الملف في حد ذاته وثم في
تسييره تم تكوين وانشاء الادانه بطريقه
تعسفيه من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه
انتصرت وجهه النظر الرسميه حول ما يحصل
فيما جاء على لسان الرئيس قيس سعيد حين
وصف الموقوفين بالمجرمين والارهابيين
والمتامرين على امن الدوله معتبرا محاسبت
هؤلاء واجبا وطنيا
يتوتر المشهد السياسي في تونس على اكثر من
صعيد جدل الايقافات وما تثيره من تمديد
داخلي ودولي يتزامن مع تازم اجتماعي يواصل
من خلاله اتحاد الشغل تصعيده عبر التحركات
الاحتجاجيه
سلسله تحركات عماليه اسبوعيه يقودها اتحاد
الشغل لتشمل جميع الولايات في حركه
احتجاجيه تصعيديه ضد ما يصفه باستهداف
السلطه للعمل النقابي بعد اعتقاد احد
النقابيين والملاحقه القضائيه لاخرين يرى
الاتحاد ان استهدافه ياتي على خلفيه موقفه
الذي وصف فيه نهج الرئيس بالاستبداد
والتفرد في الحكم
لا للاستبداد والتفرج في الحكم
السماع التونسي والمواطنين لا لتحويل
التونسي الى
هاجمونا
يزداد الوضع تعقيدا في تونس اذا امام حاله
الاضطراب الاجتماعي والسياسي وتقلص فرص
الذهاب نحو حوار سياسي جامع بعد موقف
الرئيس الاخير الذي انتقد فيه مبادره
اتحاد الشغل للانقاذ في الاثناء يمضي قيس
سعيد في نهجه الذي يصفه بمعركه التحرير
الوطني وتتمسك المعارضه برفضه واعتباره
خروجا عن الشرعيه والمسار الديمقراطي
ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره ت